first of all human reasoning did not
evolve as a way of figuring out the
world it evolved as a means for us
providing plausible sounding
justifications for what it is that we
want to get in a social situation so we
you know we reason in order to come up
with good excuses for why what we want
is what everybody should want to it is a
a source of cognitive bias it means that
we we but we are not capable
ourselves of detecting or smelling our
own okay so that's part one of
the AR
the second part of the argument is where
it gets really interesting that we are
terrible at detecting our own
but because this is so important you
know so because we are a social uh
species we are by and large we're pretty
good at detecting others and so
then this means that uh you can harness
people's cognitive bias against each
other so you and I disagree strenuously
on sort of I don't know who who who has
to pay for dinner I've got great
arguments on my side you've got great
arguments on your side uh but are but
probably at the beginning we don't have
great arguments I've got terrible
arguments and you round immediately on
the flaw in my argument and I round on
the flaw in your argument but at the
very least we end up with better
arguments so the fundamental notion here
is that individual level cognitive flaws
can result in better group level
reasoning if we are prepared to engage
with other people who we disagree with
what this is it suggests that you can
use people's Tendencies to be
as the fuel for actual good not
collaboration but for actually obser
figuring stuff out there is a work that
has been done by a Chicago sociologist
James Evans he uses uh he and his
colleagues use national natural language
processing to look at Wikipedia and to
look at the the amount of disagreement
there is on Wikipedia pages and the uh
fundamental finding that they find is
that the greater the degree of
polarization and attention that there is
in a given Wikipedia talk page the
better the quality of the resulting
argument so this is not because people
end up loving each other and singing
Kumbaya they still hate each other at
the end of the day uh but they
grudgingly recognize that there are good
arguments it's kind of like that uh
onion article the worst person I know
just made a great argument this is the
logic that we can actually harness to
make Democratic institutions work better
and Wikipedia because it is able to
harness the someone on the Internet is
wrong thing and make that into a force
of intellectual Discovery is a very very
interesting model for us to do
it